assassination it's the family trade we
all take it up and my parents see me as
an exceptional prospect but I don't see
why I should have to live up to their
expectations hello and welcome to hunt
down to 101 the series it breaks down
everyone and everything in the Hunter
hunter world today we are going to be
exploring the fan favorite child
assassin kilowatt soul dick Killa
whistle dick is a seemingly cheerful
young boy harboring an incredibly
violent and bloodthirsty side who is
first introduced to us during the hunter
exam och kilowatt is the third son of
silver and kikyo zoldak who served as
the leading figures of the Tzadik family
the world's deadliest collective of
assassins as a result kilowatt was born
with incredible natural talent and after
having been trained by both his father
silver and older brother alumi killer
proved to be a Master Assassin at an
extraordinarily young age Killa was
training routinely put him in
life-or-death situations and he was
forced by his father to participate in
combat at the heavens' arena where after
fighting for two years he managed to
reach the 204 despite all of this at a
certain point in killer was childhood
the zoldak family deemed that he lacked
the mindset of a true assassin and as a
measure of course correction allah miyan
planted a special needle into killers
brain in order to remodel his
personality through the medium of fear
in this way the needle would heavily
inform killer was decision making
throughout most of the series as well as
instilling a great sense of artificial
fear of those stronger than him a
primary example of which being illumi
himself but living in fear of villainy
was one of many uniquely awful family
dynamics for Kilowog and he had equally
strenuous relationships with his parents
and other siblings with the sole
exception of his youngest sister Aloka
the term killer actually shared quite a
normal familial relationship despite her
how shall we put this dark side but even
with LME's needle correction by the age
of 11 killer became tired of the world
of assassins and rebelled against his
family by running away from home and
deciding to take the hunter exam for the
fun of it and given that the hunter exam
is a brutally difficult world class test
that should give you some indication as
to the ridiculous strength in which
kilowatt entered the series with during
the exam kilowatt would meet a boy named
confreaks whom he immediately befriended
and this action should not be
understated because up until this point
in his life killer wood did not have a
single person in the world whom he was
able to consider a friend but his
friendships with ganja spawn so
naturally that it took killer himself by
surprise and this would eventually
evolved into an exceptionally powerful
bond and on several occasions kilowatt
would come to blatantly ignore his
training as an assassin
and put guns were being above his own
for the most part though the hunter
examined quite smoothly for Gila however
in the final phase he was thrown into
combat against his brother illumi who
had also been taking the exam in a
clever disguise due to the influence of
ill amis needle killer was forced to
surrender the match and he subsequently
murdered another participant thus
failing the hunter exam due to the
unique rules of the final stage that
forbid killing afterwards killer will
return to cook kuru mountain the
residents of the Tzadik family here
kilowatt casually allowed himself to be
tortured for three weeks by his
particularly sadistic brother Malucci
but more importantly after that killer
has a conversation with his father silva
which results in silver recognizing
killer as his own person and allowing
him to reunite with gone killer where
then took on to the heavens arena in
order to assist him in becoming stronger
and it would be here that the two would
learn about nen from a man named wing
kilowatt was able to master the four
major principles of nen in an
astonishingly short amount of time and
furthermore discovered that he was a
natural transmuter meaning that he was
able to change the properties of his nen
to mimic specific attributes of
something else and killer has primarily
taken advantage of this affinity in
order to replicate the properties of
electricity and can use them in an
offensive manner to directly shock
opponents and he can also channel it
through objects such as his yo-yos
although the pinnacle of Killa was an N
abilities thus far is the use of
godspeed a combination of two parts ooh
which utilizes his electric aura to
allow him to transcend regular physical
limitations in regards to pure agility
although it should also be noted that
the control of an n substance like this
is only possible due to killer's
background as an assassin where he was
often subject to electrical torture his
partner of regular training and
punishment unfortunately this ability
also comes with a couple of detracting
factors one of which being the kilowatt
must quote-unquote charge himself before
engaging in the use of this aura which
is accomplished via direct exposure to
electricity such as tasing himself
furthermore kill aware at this stage
also seems to be quite unaware of
exactly how much ore he discharges in
any given action which results in his
aura depleting rapidly and unexpectedly
however the discovery of these abilities
came as a result of his journey with
gone as after their stint at the heavens
arena they went on to face conflict with
the phantom troupe in Europe new city
and then proceeded to find their way
into the game Great Island in order to
search for God's father Jing during this
arc killer would find a new nen master
in Biscay who went on to teach him the
more advanced applications of the art
form however killer's relationship with
Biscay would probably be best described
as comically volatile but with his
newfound abilities killer was able to
complete the great island game along
with gone
and went on to be transported to the and
of Cockaigne and encountered another
hunter named kite a student of gongs
father from here kilowatt would become
heavily involved in the Chimera ant arc
and it would be during this time that he
would finally confront the fear that had
plagued him for the entire series as he
sensed and ripped out the needle
implanted into his brain by illumi with
this restriction lifted Kilwa was now
capable of acting for himself and became
able to devote himself fully to the art
of offense which immediately resulted in
the decapitation of Ramat a particularly
powerful chimera ant whom kilowatt was
previously unable to defeat and using
his newfound autonomy Killough it became
part of chairman metros official
extermination team and went on to take
part in the palace invasion with his
most evident action being his brief
conflict with yupi one of the three
royal guards of Mara want the Chimera
ant king and kill his own words this
battle was more about venting his own
personal frustration upon the Royal
Guard and from the outside this fight
was entirely one-sided with kilowatt
landing blow after blow with no chance
for you P to react whatsoever
with that said kilowatt was unable to
inflict any real damage on the absurd
powerhouse it is you P however the fact
that kilowatt completely outclassed the
Royal Guard in terms of speed gives us a
great sense of just how insane killer
was and in abilities are even if they
can only be invoked for a short amount
of time additionally at the tail end of
the palace invasion it felt killer to
save an enraged and overcome by despair
gone who had invoked an overwhelming
amount of nen but at the potential cost
of his own life thankfully killer was
able to get gone to help in time however
he remained on the verge of death
determined to save his best friend
kilowatts more return to cookery
mountain in order to free his younger
sister Aloka who had been sealed in
strict containment to due to the fact
that she was possessed by a creature
from the Dark Continent known as nanny
Co like all beings from the Dark
Continent nanika possesses incredible
power which killer was able to invoke in
order to save gone from the brink of
death after Gods recovery kilowatt and
Alec are then accompanied him to the
World Tree other killer would decline
the offer to climate as by this point he
had resolved to become a proper elder
brother to both alaqah and Anika
swearing to protect them and then
embarking on a new journey across the
world some more fun facts about kilowatt
of each of the four main protagonists of
Hunter hunter kilowatt is the only one
who actually failed the hunter exam
although he did take the exam once again
in the following year and passed with
flying colors in regards to his younger
sister Alec ah it should be said that
the only reason why kill a bird did not
free her earlier in life was also due to
the influence of ill amis very annoying
needle interestingly enough killer
appears to be
highly susceptible to gambling becoming
easily addicted to games of chance such
as slot machines and was once even going
to go so far as to bet his life in order
to win a jackpot furthermore kilowatt is
also heavily invested in the world of
sweets and was known to spend almost 200
million jeni on snacks during his stay
at heavens arena which leads us to a
truly useless fact which is at killer's
favorite type of candy a choco Robo kun
chocolate balls but that pretty much
does it for kilowatt if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new world revue
patreon because the support of all of
your amazing people is what continues to
make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps spot
this channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured on
the next Hunter hunter 101
[Music]
but you know what of all of kilo has
incredible achievements in life
we'll always remember that one time when
he was unable to take a ball from an old
man don't look at me like that